President Trump calling out liberal city
war zones for refusing federal help is
violence and crime spirals out of
control shootings and murders surging in
major cities as cops continue to come
under attack disturbing new images show
officers including New York City's top
uniformed cop being beaten and bloodied
it happened during a protest on the
Brooklyn Bridge today the NYPD says
three cops were seriously injured and
multiple people were arrested
president Trump railing against
Democratic mayor's for allowing the
Anarchy to happen we have other cities
that are out of control they're like war
zones and if the city isn't going to
straightening out of local politicians
all in this case don't say this for
political reasons they're all Democrats
they're liberal left-wing Democrats and
it's almost like they think this is
going to be this way forever we're not
going to put up with that we're not
gonna put up with that and Trump teasing
a big law enforcement announcement next
week will have another announcement next
week the Attorney General the FBI and
others concerning our cities because the
left-wing group of people that are
running our cities are not doing the job
that they're supposed to be doing
they're supposed to be asking for help
and they don't want to ask so maybe
they're proud or maybe they think it's
bad politically but we can't have happen
what's happening okay so a defunding the
police black lives matter protester Wan
slugged an officer in the head with a
2x4 right on the bridge right down where
I live in lower Manhattan all right this
is just another peaceful protest no I
think that's reprehensible and to be
condemned Jesse but let's look at the
overall picture because I think it's
important to understand that President
Trump is here hoping for a backlash
against the racial justice movement in
the United States I think he's appealing
to the racial grievance as well I think
you have to understand the facts just to
put everything in perspective that
violent crime is down sharply in this
country since the early 90s this year
even with Colvin and the
protests crime is down but lately
there's been a spike in some cities and
gun violence note that New York this
year had the same amount of gun violence
it had in 2015 but as I said to you in
an earlier show the violence is
concentrated in poor black and Hispanic
neighborhoods of you know largely among
the drug dealers and the gangs so the
reality is this is a race and class
issue and I think the underlying root
cause is you know bad schools bad
housing poor jobs poor paying jobs
unemployment but Trump is not dealing
with those root issues and polls show
Jesse I hope you know this polls show
that Americans don't trust Trump to deal
with racial tensions he makes things
worse
Quinnipiac has 65 percent of Americans
negative on Trump's handling of race ABC
60 percent of white people 80 percent of
Hispanics 90 percent of black people
disapprove of how this president deals
with race all right judge anine you know
Juan likes to talk about crime going
down but homicides and and shootings are
up I don't know the point of that we've
seen people being assaulted in the
streets we've seen things lit on fire I
don't care what the polls say about
Donald Trump we're talking about
protecting the safety of all Americans
the first obligation of government jesse
is the protection of its citizens and
that's not happening and Juan can talk
all he wants but in democrat-led cities
that's where it's not happening in new
york city is right behind Chicago and I
don't want to hear about how it's bad
jobs and unemployment as the reason for
this spike in crime the reason there's a
spike in crime in New York City which is
Huntly one of the highest changes that
we've seen one of the most dramatic is
because the street crime they used to
call it street crime unit the anti-crime
unit is gone and it's the minorities and
by the way the minorities are the ones
who are hurt the most and by the way
that wasn't a protest saying you know
what that was today that was a peaceful
march
by the clergy African clergy
african-american clergy along with
Hispanic clergy I just had a source tell
me on the phone before the show that
there was a black SUV handing out
baseball bats before this this march on
the Brooklyn Bridge and they were able
to take some of those bats back guys
this is about Anarchy this is about
taking America down and I don't care
what you blame it on but there has never
been this spike in crime that we've seen
the dramatic changes you tie the
police's hands behind their back you
tell them that they can't touch the
defendant the defendants are emboldened
they're taken down the cops they're
beating them with bats and we don't
understand it and that bozo de Blasio
comes out and says we got to take back
our streets well how the hell are you
gonna take back those streets you bozo
he says we got to all come together well
you know what the only way to come
together in a violent society or against
those who want to take us down is law
enforcement that's all I have to say
yeah homicides up in New York City Dana
25% I don't know if de Blasio is scared
of using the police more aggressively or
he just doesn't want to I look worse
mayor in the history of like you know
you talk about the fact that crime is
down everywhere but that doesn't happen
just like by a flip of a switch that
takes time it takes time to create
something it takes time to build
something to establish law and order and
then to hold it and to allow then a city
to thrive like New York City had but it
takes just a moment to destroy it and
we're seeing that like in the history
books like when the history of all this
is written you will be able to see like
everything going great and then BOOM all
of a sudden like when I see those
officers bleeding from their head it
breaks my heart and it also scares me
and I think that is the other thing
that's happening is that we have the
right to peacefully protest absolutely
but we also have a right to be protected
and that our civil liberties also
include the ability to be protected by
police officer
of which we are paying taxes for and we
expect for them to be allowed to do
their job and to be supported and I wish
that de Blasio would come out and
support the police but I I feel like
that is just not going to happen yeah
it's it's like Dana said Greg it's
actually just sad and I don't know what
the president has planned for this big
announcement but better be something
because the liberal mayor's aren't doing
anything it's actually I think we're at
we're in a hopeless position here I've
never felt this bad for a city and and
we keep using the word anarchy it's not
anarchy at all it's systemic crime born
from systemic disrespect for the police
systemic disinformation by the meeting
media and systemic leftism that runs
these cities we kept hearing week after
week about systemic racism well who the
hell is in charge of these cities
leftists and where are these geniuses
now what do they have to put to replace
our law and order system like what is
tomorrow supposed to look like is it
supposed to look like this because
they've offered us no no alternatives
and it seems it's got to be weird to be
in a group that dismisses all violence
as rare in an anomaly even though it
increases burning buildings how that
happens once in a decade
looting oh that sister trying to seize
that some economic justice and then
black on black crime oh just didn't poor
neighborhoods you guys it's been around
and it's got so got these systemic
problems but that's not really the issue
the issue here is boy Republicans and
conservatives and people who live in New
York who are scared crapless are gonna
pounce on this issue they're gonna turn
it into a racial issue they're gonna use
it to go after black lives matters no
we're not using it to go after anybody
we are scared as we are scared to death
of what's happening to our neighborhoods
I've got people on my staff they can't
walk to work anymore because their
problem they're women they can't walk
six freaking blocks from their apartment
to Fox because they're scared and they
are rightfully scared if you see the
streets in New York manner to blow your
mind you think it would go back to the
1970s and that would be bad dude this is
70 AD the savagery is unbelievable I you
know here's the thing
the problem with violence and trashing a
city in ruining a country it's
incredibly persuasive visual evidence I
will never forget June 2020 and neither
should Trump so this has to be really
really practical a friend of mine once
said to me he said you can tell when
something is meaningful when it causes
you to act and I don't mean going on TV
with a monologue I mean doing something
to protect my family for the first time
on my life I acted and I went and I
bought a firearm like millions of other
Americans because we saw visual evidence
that we weren't going to be protected
anymore that the cavalry wasn't going to
come that when we were going to call 911
to make it so now it's up to us as
American citizens to practice our write
of the Second Amendment and I'm sorry if
that looks like you're pouncing on
social justice warriors no it's to
protect our family and it's offensive
it's offensive to marginalize people's
concern over violence makes me sick to
my stomach should make everybody sick to
their stomach